Okay.
Last time I talked about the letter to the Hebrews and I used it mainly as an
example of early Christian interpretation of scripture.
And if you'll recall,
I was talking about Hebrews seven where there's the story,
the interpretation of the Melk Kisa deck story from Genesis to review briefly.
Abraham comes back from a raid.
Uh,
he has a lot of booty.
He has his relatives from defeating some kings.
He comes to milk Kisa deck,
who's not,
uh,
of course,
just in,
in a vapor ham.
Therefore he's not a Jew.
He's not part of the people of Israel.
Uh,
but he is a priest,
high priest of Yahweh.
According to the text.
Mel Kizza deck gives him a 10th of the spoils.
And then this writer interprets that as being that since Levi,
the head of the,
the progenitor of the priestly tribe in among the Jews is within the body of
Abraham that needs,
that Levi himself is giving tithes to milk is a deck.
So the entire priesthood of the,
of the,
of Israel,
of the Jews recognizes the superiority according to this interpretation of the
priesthood of Melchizedek.
And then the writer takes them out.
Kiradech to be a type a sign of Jesus and his priesthood.
And this makes perfect sense of course,
because as the text says,
[inaudible] had no father or mother or the tech.
He doesn't give a,
it does give a father,
mother and no one know genealogy.
No lineage came out of north.
So the same way happens with Christ as the priesthood.
Christ is not.
Jesus' of course,
was not of the tribe of Levi according.
So Jesus couldn't be a tribe in the norm.
Um,
uh,
a priest in the normal sense of the Jewish priesthood.
So the writer takes Jesus to be a priest,
not of the represent the line of Levi or Aaron,
but of the line of milk is a deck.
Now,
this obviously is not the way any of us in the modern world who had read genesis
and its historical setting that's precisely to the way this reader does it.
And it's all part of a synchronous,
a comparison of the led toward Ghia,
the liturgy of Christ with the inferior let tore Ghia,
our liturgy of the Jews.
So,
and it's done.
So to convince this congregation that you don't need to go back to that you've
got something superior.
So Hebrews ends with this kind of,
um,
admonition in a chapter 13
a chapter 13 verse eight.
Jesus Christ is the same yesterday and today and forever.
Now remember,
this writer believes that Jesus Christ has existed all the way back.
So that's why he can read the psalms,
which a historian would be,
would read his address to a Davidic king as being addressed actually to Jesus.
So Jesus crosses back in history to do not be carried away by all kinds of
strange teachings for it as well.
For the heart to be strengthened by grace,
not by regulations about food are,
you don't need to keep kosher,
which have not benefited those who observe them.
We have an altar from which those who officiate in the tent.
See that's referring to that tabernacle,
the tent of Tabernacle in an exodus,
which has been comparing all the way through.
We have an alter from which those who officiate in the tent,
that is the Levi.
It's have no right to eat for the bodies of those animals whose blood is brought
into the sanctuary by the high priest as a sacrifice for sin are burned outside
the camp.
When you sacrifice an animal according to the exodus instructions,
you don't burn them the materials of the sacrifice inside the camp.
You do it outside the camp.
So he's going to do something like that to therefore Jesus also suffered,
were outside the gates of Jerusalem.
So now Jerusalem has become like the Israelite camp,
talked about an exodus,
and Jesus is the sacrifice who has sacrificed on the cross outside the walls of
Jerusalem.
Um,
Jesus suffered outside the city gates in order to sanctify the people by his own
blood.
Let us then,
now this is really a really big period on this whole speech.
Let us then go to him outside the camp.
Basically,
he is symbolically saying,
let us follow Jesus out of Jerusalem,
out of the camp of the Israelites.
Now this is much more radically,
uh,
supersessionism than we've seen in Paul.
I've taught that Paul never saw himself as a Christian.
He never saw himself as starting something new.
In fact,
he saw himself as as bringing the gentiles into Israel.
And so he never,
uh,
although they didn't have to keep the law,
they didn't have to keep Torah.
They didn't have to be circumcised.
In fact,
they weren't supposed to at all be circumcised.
Paul never thought,
he never talks in this way about the super session of a new kind of liturgy from
an old kind of liturgy.
But so when you talk about Christian,
super session is kind of language and that the term just means the Christian
traditional Christian teachings that you've seen throughout 2000 years of
Christianity,
that Christianity is superior to Judaism.
When you see that kind of super session is kind of language in the New
Testament,
it's not impulsive much.
It is here in Hebrews because that's the way it works.
But what's interesting from our point of view is that he actually uses Jewish
scripture to teach this now in order to use Jewish scripture to teach the super
session of Judaism by Christianity,
you know,
that he's going to have to interpret it.
And what we would consider very creative ways.
And that's what that we can use that to contrast the way I've been teaching you
to interpret these texts in this course,
which is through historical critical Exige Jesus from the way that Christians
have interpreted this text for all the way through,
uh,
history.
And this is not just Christians,
Jewish interpretation of scripture is just as creative as Christian
interpretation of scripture before the modern period.
So what,
what then is historical criticism,
and I'm going to review some things that you've been learning all the way
through the semester,
but I'm going to line up some things so that get them really clear in your mind.
What is it you've been learning in this class,
the method you've been learning.
And then we're gonna go back to the pre modern stuff today and look at the
examples that you read about in the reading from the pedagogy of the Bible book.
The meaning of a text according to historical criticism is what the ancient
human author intended it to mean.
So for example,
in Jeremiah three six it says,
the Lord said to me in the days of King Josiah.
Now,
if I wanted to be creative in my interpretation,
I might say that the Lord said to me,
they all Basil Martin in the days of King Josiah.
But that would of course not be a historical critical interpretation.
It has to be me,
meaning Jeremiah.
So the Lord says to Jeremiah,
that's who the author clearly must be referring to.
And we have to take the King Josiah to be the king who actually sat on the
throne of David in Jerusalem,
the ancient king,
Josiah Nott,
Josiah Bumbershoot,
who happens to own a liquor store down the street from me.
The text is not referring to that Josiah.
He's referring to the ancient Josiah basis of historical criticism.
The expansion of this,
that it's the author's intention comes to be in a lot of studies,
even in the Ma,
even within historical criticism,
that another way to think about the meaning of the text is that the meaning of
the text is what the original readers probably would have thought it meant.
Because of course even we can't get to the intensity of the author that's lost.
So it's completely,
we have no idea what's going on inside the mind of these ancient authors.
But by practicing historic graphical research,
we can guess at what probably an ancient writer would have taken the text to
mean.
And so that's been added on as another meaning that that historical criticism
looks for.
The third point about historical consciousness I want to make here is that about
his historical criticism is that it assumes a sort of modern historical
consciousness.
By what?
By this we mean modern people just have the notion that really premodern people
didn't so much that the world was radically different in the ancient world.
The ancient world is just not like our world.
They thought about the world as being in levels like stories.
While we think about the cosmos being bunch of different spheres and an infinite
space.
So we read ancient text and we see not only were they different kinds of people,
they had different ethics,
but their whole cosmos,
their whole universe that they inhabited was different for them.
So what that means when with historical criticism in the 20th century,
you have theological students being taught a little bit about ancient near
eastern society and culture.
In fact,
you have entire departments of ancient near eastern studies arise in modern
universities and they don't arise just because people are automatically
interested in ancient near eastern cultures.
They arise as a support for biblical studies.
That's where they come from.
The idea that if you want to read the Old Testament of the Hebrew Bible
responsibly in the modern world,
you must know something about ancient Assyria and ancient Egypt cause that's
where it came from.
And also then you learn something about the Greek world.
Why I gave an entire lecture at the beginning of this semester on the Greek
world and the Roman world and Second Temple Judaism.
We have the idea that uh,
Judaism before the rabbis,
which is the time Judy,
you were talking about,
was a different kind of Judaism than Rabbinic Judaism that you might see now in
the modern world or in the Middle Ages.
This reflects the idea that if you want to get into back into these texts in
their ancient period,
you have to develop knowledge of that period.
Why?
Because we've developed a historical consciousness.
We see ourselves in a place,
in a timeline of history,
and the history is different in those different times.
This also means that we teach people you need to read these texts if possible in
the original languages.
How many times in this class have I told you what the original Greek word,
if some particular,
where are we?
The English translation was,
this is not a Greek class.
Most of you haven't studied Greek,
but I'll often scribble on the board some Greek term.
Why am I doing that?
The text that Christians read all over the world today is not in Greek.
It's an English,
so why is it important for us?
Why do you accept that that's important?
Why does it seem natural to you that I write the Greek text up here and explain
what it's Greek meaning means in the ancient world?
Because you have his historical consciousness too.
You have the assumption that this ancient meaning of the original languages is
important for the interpretation of this text.
Fourth,
we,
historical criticism teaches you we don't interpret the Bible canonically
and that means a couple of different things.
We don't take the whole can in the Bible and interpret it all by reference to
other parts of the Canon.
Remember,
how many times have we said,
well,
that thing you're talking about maybe in the gospel of John,
but it's not in the gospel of Matthew and right now we're talking about the
gospel of Matthew.
You can't use the gospel of John to interpret the Gospel of Matthew.
Well,
why not?
Christians have been doing it for 2000 years.
Historical criticism though,
takes the canon apart and says each individual document must be studied in its
own right and for its own content.
So this also,
so that's one thing it means is that we don't study the whole Bible as one book.
We studied the Bible as a series,
as a library of books,
each one individually studied.
The other aspect of this is that we in art in the modern period don't limit
ourselves to the study of the Canon.
What did we talk about last week?
The acts of Paul and Thecla that's not in the Bible.
Why did I as a crazy mixed up professor that I am think that it was for you to
read I non-canonical second century document in a class called introduction to
New Testament history and literature.
I'll tell you why.
I've been brainwashed by the modern historical critical method to believe that
putting the pastoral epistles and those other canonical texts into a historical
context that included non-canonical materials.
Is that a good way to teach you how to think about this new testament thing
that's part of the historical critical method also fifth,
in spite of the fact that we don't study the Bible canonically in modern
historical criticism,
we actually do look for source analysis.
So,
for example,
we take the idea that these ancient authors actually did use sources.
And since,
for example,
we,
we've taught you that Matthew and Luke probably used mark as one of their
sources.
And so that's actually doing an intro canonical comparison.
We compare the shape of this parable in mark to the shape of the same parable in
Matthew and Luke.
Isn't that kind of canonic inter canonical comparison?
Yes it is.
But the reason we're doing is we're trying to get behind the text of the Canon
into the prehistory of the text.
The form these,
these texts assumed in a pre canonical shape.
So famously historical criticism in the 19th century when it was really
invented,
came up with the idea that the five books of Moses are not written by Moses.
They're written by different people.
And they were an addition of originally four separate strains of tradition in
four separate documents.
This was called the j e p d theory.
The J stands for Yahweh east and it's those parts of the Hebrew Bible use the
name of God as Y'all way because this came from Germany,
right?
So they pronounced a j like,
yeah,
so [inaudible],
uh,
the Los [inaudible] is a strain that uses the term Elohim for God.
So scholars said these are two originally,
two different things.
The p stands for the priestly documents written by some kind of priestly class
and the Deuce,
the d stands for Deuteronomy.
So Deuteronomy and some other things now.
And the idea was the deuteronomist was an editor who wrote some of this stuff
and then edited the five books,
uh,
or at least a good bit of the Pinta took so that it resembled a certain shape.
So scholars called,
they set up these four different traditions and if you took a course in Hebrew
Bible and introduction to Hebrew Bible or even in a seminary introduction to Old
Testament,
you're going to get this theory crammed down your throat because it's one of the
most dominant theories of modern historical criticism of the Hebrew Bible.
It's source analysis.
That's part of what we're doing.
I taught also the second Peter,
the letter of second Peter used Jude as one of his sources.
Again,
that kind of source analysis as part of the method.
The next one.
I think I'm,
I think I'm up to six in spite of the fact of talking about authorship of all
these documents,
part of modern historical criticism questions,
the authenticity of authorship all the time.
How many times in this course of I said,
well,
the Gospel say they're written by Matthew,
mark,
Luke,
and John,
but weed out they were,
they're anonymous so that I've taught you what it means to call a document
anonymous.
We don't know who the author is.
I've taught you what it means to call a document sue,
to pick a pseudo [inaudible] or pseudonymous,
which means it gives the false name.
Oh,
somebody for what it is.
These are basic aspects of modern historical criticism.
Now if you went to a very his,
if you went to a very conservative seminary,
you might not get as much emphasis on this,
but even there,
they'll probably tell you something like,
well,
those liberals at Yale or Princeton theological seminary,
they'll tell you that Paul didn't write first and second Timothy and Titus,
but they're wrong.
And here's why they're wrong.
But you can tell you in the modern period because they feel the need to explain
the theory to you anyway.
Even if they don't buy it,
they'll teach it to you because it's part of this modern way of approaching the
Bible.
Next,
the avoidance of anachronism.
This is the big bad thing in modern historical criticism.
Don't be anachronistic.
Don't think back into the ancient text,
something that actually arose later.
So for example,
most historical critics of the Bible would say,
it's certainly wrong to read the doctrine of the trinity into Genesis.
Now,
you already read in the Chapter I gave you that.
That's exactly what Augustine does,
right?
Agustine sees,
read the first chapter of Genesis.
And when the text says in,
um,
in the beginning he says,
that refers to Jesus the way the sun,
the wisdom through whom all things were made,
the spirit that hovers over the chaos in genesis one that refers to the Holy
Spirit.
So you got the trinity,
the God,
Father,
son,
and Holy Spirit,
right in genesis,
modern historical criticism rejects that and says,
that's wildly anachronistic.
The doctrine of the trinity was only developed centuries after the writing of
genesis.
You can't read it back in there.
It's an anachronism.
And the last big,
big boogie man of a historical criticism is [inaudible] Jesus.
If you go to any kind of seminary,
they'll warn you against ICIJ Jesus,
right?
Cause this is reading into the text,
something that's not in the text and they're playing off the word.
Of course,
I've used this before.
Exit Jesus.
Do you just mean simply as you've already learned in this course,
interpreting a text?
Some people think it only refers to historical critical interpretation,
and that's often what it's come to mean in schools.
But originally just means interpreting a text.
Any kind of interpretation of a text.
[inaudible] Jesus,
but it's come to mean historical critical interpretation of the text because
this is what's really in the text and what is Icij?
Jesus is just some modern,
pious person picking up the Bible and seeing it in anything they want to see in
it.
It's reading into,
because this,
this means out of in this Greek word means into,
so I see Jesus,
you're taught to avoid that.
And then finally,
one of the last major presuppositions that relates to the historical
consciousness.
I about the idea that there's a gap between the world of the Bible and our
world.
If you go into most churches in the United States,
they're very,
very few that might do this.
But if you go into most churches,
I don't care how liberal or how conservative they are,
I don't care if there are radical leftist are fundamentalists.
Most of the women will not be wearing veils.
Yeah.
If they're really conservative,
they might have a hat on,
but not a full veil.
And we say what you are,
you want to be true to the Bible.
And right there in First Corinthians 11 you've read it.
You know,
it's their gut.
Paul's telling women you have to wear veils and church when you pray and
prophesied,
why aren't your women veiled?
And it doesn't matter whether these Christians are liberal or Conservative,
they'll have some way of saying something like,
well,
that was their culture and it's not our culture.
So it was important in the ancient world for women to wear a belt because it's
pressed,
uh,
humility expressed control.
If they didn't wear veils,
they might be thought of as a loose woman.
Well,
veils don't mean that in our culture,
so we don't have to obey that text.
Like it's a rule they will talk about and they might not use the term gap,
but that's what I'd call it.
What they're doing is saying there's a gap between their culture and their world
and ours.
That consciousness of that gap is a major aspect of modern historical criticism.
Now.
So those are several principles.
You're not going to probably find those listed in a textbook introduction to the
Bible.
Uh,
I actually do list them and my pedagogy,
the Bible book in the first chapter.
But those are a list of things that I just backed in and said,
these are basic principles of historical criticism that set it apart from the
centuries of interpretation of the Bible that have existed beforehand.
So I'm going to stop from it and just say,
is that clear?
Do you have any questions yet?
This is all familiar to you because you've been practicing this now all year,
but it should have been a little,
it's true.
Struck some of you as the east.
A little odd in the beginning of why we were asking this text what we were
doing,
why we were pushing you to do the,
the,
the xds of Everest in a certain way.
We're doing,
why is it wrong to read these texts and just write a sermon on them and turn it
in as an ex Jesus paper?
No,
a sermon is different from an exit Jesus paper.
We were teaching you this method with all these principles and presuppositions
all semester long.
So is there any question about that?
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
but this historical criticism visit didn't just spring out of the Bible itself.
So where did it come from?
Why do we have it and where did it come from?
Well,
as you know,
before the reformation,
basically the Bible scripture was supposed to mean what the Catholic Church
said.
It meant what the pope said it.
Wait,
what the what the bishop sediment.
So the authority structure of the church was taken to be the way that you
controlled wild interpretations.
And people in the ancient world knew you can interpret a text anyway you want
to.
So what keeps Harrison heretics from interpreting this text and false ways,
the institution of the church.
So we'll see later,
um,
Ignatius when read his letters,
he says,
you can't just interpret scripture any way you want to.
You must be in agreement with your bishop.
So that the rule of the bishop and the role of the church was the way to keep
control over the interpretation of the text.
And of course,
in the pre reformation time,
you did have the rise of humanism and the renaissance,
which started questioning that a bit.
And they started,
they started going back and looking at their original Hebrew,
the original Greek,
insisting that you should read these texts in their original languages and not
just in Latin.
So that was before the reformation.
You already had this move toward history and reading the texts and historical
context and the humanist movement and the renaissance with the reformation
though,
of course,
you really get it in the 16th century with Martin Luther,
John Calvin,
Melanchthon,
different,
uh,
writers saying,
well,
we're going to throw out this Catholic authority on the text.
We're going to get back to the text itself.
So the only authority for the radical reformers,
what scripture,
and so you know this as Sola Scriptura,
scripture only scripture only will be the guide for authority for Protestants.
But of course then they start realizing that different people can interpret
scripture differently.
They're very familiar with medieval Christian ways of interpreting scripture to
have several different meanings and layers of meanings.
And so they say,
well,
the predominant guide of scripture isn't going to be just scripture.
It's going to be how one particular meaning of scripture,
and that's census litter Alice.
Yeah.
The literal sense of scripture is what will be now the guide for the rep
reformation,
not the pope,
not the bishops.
Even the bishop must submit to the literal sense of scripture.
Now it's rather debatable what they meant by the literal sense,
because some of these reformers said that the literal sense of scripture could
even be a prophetic sense.
So they was still said that the literal sense of scripture could be in a psalm.
The Psalm says,
the Lord said to my Lord,
sit at my right hand.
Well,
they knew that the profit,
you know the,
the text if you're going to sit in an ancient text would be referring to the
diabetic king.
But they also said that som also could refer to Jesus even in its literal sense.
So the literal sense that they were talking about in the reformation was not
necessarily what we would call the historical critical sense.
It was what they took it to be the most fundamental plain sense meaning of the
text.
So that was the literal sense.
But then again,
they realize the more they did this,
that Protestant churches started splitting all over the place.
Presbyterians and Calvinist split off from the,
the little,
the Lutherans,
the Anabaptist put off from the reformation.
You have,
then you have a rise of so many Protestant movements.
The idea that scripture alone could settle debates and give you a foundation
started becoming questionable.
And in the 19th beginning,
somewhat in the 18th century,
but mainly in the 19th century and mainly in Germany or German speaking lands,
scholars started pushing the historical reading of the text.
They said,
okay,
we've got to get down to what the author meant.
What did the historical Paul mean?
And we had to,
we discover that.
And so that's when you have the rise in the 19th century of the dominance of the
historical critical method with all these presuppositions,
it was elaborated and invented in the 19th century.
And in some places it was precisely invented in order to try to make some the
text of the New Testament and the Bible Affirm Foundation for doctrine and
ethics and within Protestantism and within the wide varieties of different kinds
of Protestantism.
And then the last thing that,
the last part of this,
this is a big sweep of history I'm giving you,
you know,
in five seconds what happens in the lab last part of the 20th century,
just in the last say 30 years,
is that people like me come along and say,
you know,
it hasn't worked.
This attempt to use historical criticism to settle disputes about the meaning of
the text doesn't work because even the historical critical method can render
wildly varying interpretations of these texts.
So you got some people reading Romans one as a condemnation of modern
homosexuality and thinking they're doing a good historical reading of this text.
You got other people who read the same text using the same methods of historical
criticism and say,
are you crazy?
It's not talking about homosexuality.
There's not,
it's not.
It's not as concerned.
It's talking about idolatry or something else.
So even scholars using the same method of historical criticism,
trained in the same schools,
getting degrees from the same places,
come up with different interpretations of these texts,
even using historical critical method.
And that's why you have right now a lot of questioning of this method as not
supplying the from foundations that Protestants originally thought it might.
So you have new methods now being brought back into seminary education like
feminist analysis are literary criticism.
Our Liberation Theology or African American,
uh,
approaches are Latino approaches.
You have all kinds or queer readings,
gay lesbian readings and queer readings.
You have all of these different kinds of ways of approaching the text being
brought back as ways to,
if not displaced,
then at least to supplement historical criticism that was dominant for the 20th
century.
Now the question is why?
Why do all this weight and stuff anyway,
why have I first been teaching you the historical critical method?
Well,
I can answer that is because that's the dominant way that the Bible is taught in
modern American universities.
It's sort of like how do you learn Shakespeare?
How do you learn these kinds of things?
There are methods,
and it's not necessarily the historical method and English departments anymore,
but there are different dominant methods that academics use to construct their
disciplines.
And the main way still that biblical studies as constructed as an academic
discipline as opposed to a discipline of faith in a church is through the,
at least learning about the historical critical method.
So I make that the basic,
basic part of this when I'm introducing you to this discipline,
because I'm not just introducing to the text,
I'm introducing you to a modern scholarly discipline practices,
assumptions.
But I also believe that we should study other ways of studying the Bible also at
least to be introduced to them.
That's why for the later this week,
you're supposed to go to the art museum.
None of us who are struggled,
critics who are working in this class.
I'm not a,
I'm not,
I mean not.
None of us are art critics.
None of us are historians of art.
I know nothing about art history.
The teaching fellows know very little about art history.
Also some of you in this class we'll note be much better at going through the
Yale Art Gallery and analyzing the artwork there because you will have taken art
history classes like I never did.
The purpose of this visit is not to do it.
A typical art historical kind of move it so that you can contrast the stuff
you've been learning in this course with especially early Christian and medieval
representations of the Bible.
Why did they portray in painting and an artwork?
These stories,
the way they portray it,
what does it tell us about their mentality?
What does it tell us about their world and and to get you to see this is what
interpretations of the Bible look like without historical criticism before the
dominance of historical criticism.
So it's to show you there are other quite legitimate ways to interpret this
text.
We could have done this sort of literary interpretation where we take these
texts and we'd talk about things like character developmental plot.
We could read the gospel of mark.
A lot of people read the gospel of mark as almost like a modern short story.
It has its full of puzzles.
It has its full of ways that it leads the reader.
Oh,
stray.
Remember how the gospel of Mark Ends?
You don't even see the resurrected Jesus.
The women are told to go announce these,
raised to the disciples and they don't even do it.
They run off and that's the end.
That doesn't end like a normal ancient text would end it.
But it does end like kind of modernist sort of literature,
which poses is up mini questions to the reader often as it does give answers.
So we could have read the gospel of Mark,
like we would read a modern short story by Flannery O'connor.
You can do that and there's nothing wrong with that.
And I,
and I,
why is all that important?
I think is important to realize that because the vast majority of Christians
throughout human history have not read the Bible the way you're learning to read
it in this class,
and the vast majority of Christians,
even now throughout the world,
don't read the Bible as you're learning to read it in this class.
And in spite of the fact that I'm teaching you this method,
I still want to drum it into your heads at least this week,
that this is just one way of doing it.
And you need to be aware of the other ways of doing it because in some ways they
are culturally more important as far as the impact of the Bible on Western
civilization.
Yeah.
So what I'm saying is that historical criticism is important to learn because
it's part of our environment too.
But I would say it is even as an important way to approach the Bible,
it's not a sufficient way to approach the Bible.
It's certainly not sufficient when it comes to the importance of scripture in
the Bible for Western civilization and culture.
It'd be much better to keep in mind how Milton read the Bible for Paradise lost,
how,
uh,
Dante read the Bible,
how Flannery O'connor uses the Bible in our literature and how artists use the
Bible.
That's also very important.
And it certainly historical who doesn't is not sufficient for the Christian
theological reading of the Bible because the historical meaning of the text I
think is people are beginning to realize in churches cannot provide you with
enough to use this text theologically and ethically.
You've got to do something else with the text besides just history,
if you still want to use it as scripture.
So that's why I'm today I'm mixing these things up and trying to get you to see
things differently.
So now let's look at what you were reading for today,
the different medieval interpretations at Ancient Christian and medieval
interpretations of text.
First,
you should know that before the modern period,
there were these different readings of the meanings of the text and in fact they
would even talk about it as different levels.
The two most important were the ones that I've already talked about basically as
the literal sense.
And then the other one is the allegorical sense.
And you've seen this sort of thing.
So these
eventually textbooks would be written that say medieval interpretation of the
Bible have four different levels of meaning.
But the most important throughout history has been basically the a two part
division,
this literal sense,
which sometimes can be called the body sense,
the bodily sense or the physical sense.
And then the spiritual sense or the allegorical sense or the higher meaning are
the elevated meaning.
So over and over again,
those two levels of interpretation will be stressed and pre modern
interpretation of the Bible.
And then you will often see other names and other terms attached to other
things.
For example,
sometimes you'll come across the term and a goggle sense of the text and
anagogical is not exactly the literal,
but it's also not exactly the allegorical because the ANA gods anagogical means
leading up in Greek.
So the idea was that this is a reading the text that will help you be a better
Christian.
It'll help you be a more ethical person.
So on anagogical reading would lead you to something else.
And the variety of the different ways of reading the texts.
So medieval theologians,
we'll talk about this,
don't use the term literal.
They'll use the term allegorical.
They're used the term anagogical and they'll mean by that.
Three different meanings and notice they don't necessarily just mean these are
three different ways to interpret the text.
I'll that.
That's the way I've been talking about them cause that's the way I hear that.
They actually believe that these are three different meanings that are in the
text itself.
The anagogical meaning the allegorical,
meaning the literal meaning and then sometimes you'll hear them talking about
maybe the ethical meaning which is sometimes it looks a lot like the anagogical
meaning and then sometimes you'll even hear them talk about the historical
meaning.
But what's funny here is that when they use that word Historia for the meaning
of a text and they sometimes us bring,
it's a Greek word originally they'll bring it into Latin also that don't get
confused and you see that especially if you're,
if you're reading something on medieval interpretation of the Bible cause it
doesn't mean what I've been telling you means is our sense of the term
historical meaning of the text by Historia.
In this sense they usually mean the narrative reading.
Like if you were read this text as a story,
regardless of whether it ever happened.
So they don't mean historical in the sense of this is what really happened.
They mean the word Historia and this is a narrative sort of shape as it's
reading the text as if it's telling a story.
And so sometimes they'll call that the historical meaning of the text and add
that onto some of these other ones.
So the Minnieville notion that there are four senses of the text literally is
always one.
Allegorical is always one and what counts as the other two varies among
different authors,
but that that is definitely there in medieval theorizing about scriptural
interpretation.
But it shouldn't be exaggerated because you don't see it quite that rigidly as
always for and the same four levels of meaning.
But you will come across that if you do any literary study of the Bible in
English literature and a European context in that sort of thing.
So the people I gave you to read illustrate these things.
The first part about origin,
if you brought your readings,
turn to the part about origin,
like around page 56 what origin is doing is he's giving an example of what he
takes to be the literal meaning of this text.
The story is from first Samuel 28 and in case you don't remember the story,
Saul,
who's the king is fighting a battle and he wants to know whether he's going to
win the battle the next day,
whether he and Jonathan,
his son are gonna win.
Oh,
they'll lose.
So he goes and he finds a witch and of course he's already outlawed all the
witches in in the country.
So he's not supposed to find one at all.
So it goes and find this woman.
She's actually called a belly myther,
a person who speaks fabulous stories from the belly cause I guess they would
kind of do like this [inaudible] and all sounded like it was coming out of their
gut so that they were sort of sound like you've been toilets gross or something
and they're speaking hidden messages.
So he goes and finds this woman.
It's translated off in an English,
the which of indoor,
that's the popular name for the story.
And he says,
call up the spirit of Samuel the dead profit.
And he's going to ask the spirit,
of course in,
you know,
in these kinds of cultures,
the idea is that dead people can see the future because they're dead.
They live in the realm that they're not limited by,
uh,
our kinds of site.
So the idea is that the woman's supposed to call up the dead Samuel,
the spirit of Samuel.
So he comes out of the ground like all the debt are under the ground in this
kind of cosmology.
And he's asked,
well,
are we going to win the battle?
And Samuel is all angry being called up and he curses Saul and all this kind of
stuff.
So the story doesn't end too well for Saul.
And sure enough,
the next day Saul and Jonathan Die,
they lose the battle.
So origin has a problem because Christians all know that it's wrong to use
witches.
And here's the king saw using a witch.
And they also know.
But wait a minute,
Samuel obeyed the woman,
she calls him to come out of the ground and he'll Beta,
why would a great Prophet,
Oh Bay,
a witch.
So early Christians reading this text had a lot of problems.
And so sometimes they would allegorize it and they say,
well it doesn't mean that it means this.
And it doesn't say the woman actually saw Samuel,
she saw,
she thought she saw Samuel and then other people would say,
but a good of good profit like Samuel couldn't have been in hell.
How could he have been in hell?
Great profits can't be in hell.
So they say,
oh,
it's just,
it's an allegory and said say it doesn't mean really mean he was in hell and man
he was in something else.
And origin comes along and says,
no you can't allegorize this text.
It means exactly what it says.
So he says,
you have to read it literally.
And so he,
August we're at,
and this is very funny because origin is famous throughout history for being a
great allegorizing reader of scripture.
In fact,
a lot of historians don't like him cause he reader tends to read scripture out
allegorically in different places.
But in this case,
origin,
this great allegorize sir is insisting on the literal reading.
But now notice what he means by literal.
First he says,
the woman really did see Samuel.
Samuel really was in hell,
and if you can't accept that,
it's your problem.
So then he explains it.
He gives some answers for it,
but then he says the literal meaning of the text is not just a story,
but this is what he says to the literal sense.
It's on page 56 and the Chapter I gave you,
even the literal sense of the story is to teach that Christians will enjoy an
afterlife existence.
Now I ask you,
is there anything about Christians in this story?
No.
We would not call that the literal historical sense of this story.
So it shows that origin,
when he uses this term literal meaning of the story,
he's not still referring to what we call the historical critical meaning.
But for him,
the literal meaning of the story is to teach Christians about their own
afterlife existence.
And then he has an elevated our higher sense of the story which he takes to be
that righteous Christians,
unlike even righteous prophets before the coming of Jesus won't have to spend
any time in hades or hell or purgatory.
If you're a good Christian,
when you die,
you'll go straight to heaven.
And that's something that even the Old Testament prophets didn't do because they
had to go to hell first according to origin,
to wait until Christ came.
So Christ could open up paradise in heaven for everybody.
So origin has an elevated spiritual meaning of this text,
but it's not a particularly allegorical,
meaning it's just that if you're a righteous Christian,
the story teaches that you will get to go straight to heaven without passing
through hell when you die.
So notice how origin is still playing with these notions of a literal reading
and a higher elevated spiritual reading.
But the literal reading doesn't particularly look like what we would call the
literal reading of the text and the higher elevated spiritual reading doesn't
look all that allegorical.
It looks almost like a moral lesson to us.
So that's one example though about how origin thinks it's perfectly fine to get
at least two readings out of this same text.
Then you move to Augustan.
Now Augusta is a great example because he's an example I use because of a pre
modern practice of not just reading scripture for the answers that gives you
about ethics or doctrine.
Remember that section in the readings where Augustine praise with scripture,
he's praised the psalms.
So he says things like,
then I read,
let your anger deter me from sin,
which is a quotation from psalm 44 and how these words mood me,
my God.
I had already learned to feel from my past sins and anger with myself.
That would hold me back from sending.
Again,
this is from confessions nine 10 and it's on page 57 of my chapter.
So notice what Augustans doing.
He feels like it's okay for him to get into the song and put himself in this
world of the speaker.
And so what God is saying to the Somme,
Augustan says,
he was saying to me personally,
Augustan and then Augustan answers back with the words of the Psalm.
This is actually a reading of scripture that's becoming popular more in certain
modern Christian context,
especially monastic communities and churches.
And it's called sometimes lectio Divina.
Okay.
This just means divine reading in Latin,
but it refers to a practice that some modern Christians are trying to resurrect
from the premodern Christian practices of praying,
whisk,
letting,
reading scripture,
memorizing scripture,
and then using the words of scripture as your own prayer to God so that God
talks to you and he talked about,
so people are getting this stuff straight from pre modern practices,
but Augustan is also a wonderful example of the multiplicity of meanings that
are contained in the text all at the same time.
So,
for example,
on page 58,
this is where he sees the trinity in Genesis one
in the beginning because of John One,
three through 10,
you've read the gospel of John.
The first part of John One cites this in the beginning,
but then goes on to say is that God created everything through Jesus,
the logos.
So a gun Augustan looks at that in the beginning and says,
oh,
that's a reference to John,
the gospel of John,
which means that he's talking about Jesus here is also being there and in the
spirit that moves over the waters is the Holy Spirit.
And then one of the most fascinating things is his,
the way he uses,
he reads the six days of creation in genesis and uh,
allegorically,
uh,
on page 59 and around then he says,
on the first day,
the vault,
the heavens,
God created the heavens and the earth,
right?
The word heaven,
they're translated,
uh,
doesn't mean what we think as space.
In this guy,
he referred to an actual,
um,
from kind of vault,
like a dome,
a ceiling.
And that's why an older translations,
it's called the firmament.
Because it is from,
it's not air,
it's firm.
And so Augustine says the sky,
when you look up at the sky,
you see that blue thing,
that big blue dome that's above you.
We think of that as seeing space,
but ancient people didn't.
They thought they were actually seeing like a big canvas spread over the sky.
The reason it's blue is because water's behind it.
It's holding back the water.
It's in the sky and the sky refers to the word heaven refers to that thing.
And so Augustan says it's like vellum is like the skin,
the leather that you make tech set of.
And so he interprets it allegorically to say scripture,
the making of the firmament.
And genesis refers to God's giving us scripture.
And that's why angels were to angels if they live on the other side of
scripture.
Why?
Because they don't have to see what's written because they know everything
already.
But we humans,
we live on this side of scripture and we look up and we read the writings of
God.
And so we need scripture to read things.
So he goes to this elaborate allegorical reading day.
To the waters that lit the preside over the vault.
They represent angelic peoples.
He says the angels on Day three,
the gathered together.
See,
this is when genesis says God separated the sea from the dry land.
This,
you know,
and separate the water from the dryland that what he called see the driving
called Earth.
And Augustan says,
okay,
the sea represents the bitter part of humanity.
The dry land represents those who thirst after righteousness and God.
So God separates out on day three good humanity from bad humanity by Augustans
allegorical interpretation.
So all of these just are illustrations of how Augustan knew how to read this
text literally.
But he shows you how he also reads allegorically.
He thinks that the text is full of all these meetings and it's perfectly
legitimate to get all of these meetings of the texts.
And then one of the most fascinating is want to get you from Bernard of
Clairvaux.
And I'm going to this I think is so interesting because Bernard is preaching on
the song of songs that you know,
erotic part of the Hebrew Bible,
which is actually to us,
moderns just looks like a love poem,
but it was red allegorically throughout the church and even in Rabbinic Judaism
read the song of songs as being about God and people.
Israel,
the bridegroom is God.
The bride is the people of Israel.
Christian fathers read that it'd be about Jesus and the church.
So Bernard is doing that,
but now notice this is a sermon being delivered to monks in a monastery.
These are men.
They're all men there.
And if you realize that's the social setting of this text,
it makes it read very differently.
Like this one big paragraph I quoted quoted again,
now he,
this is the young woman in the song of songs speaking in his sermon.
I cannot rest until he kisses me with a kiss of his mouth.
I thank Kim for the kiss of the feet.
I thank him too for the kiss of the hand,
but if he has genuine regard for me,
let him kiss me with the kiss of his mouth.
There is no question of in gratitude on my part.
It's simply that I am in love.
It is desire that drives me on not reason.
Please do not accuse me of presumption if I yield to this impulse of love.
My shame indeed rebukes me,
but love is stronger than all I ask.
I crave,
I implore,
let him kiss me with the kiss of his mouth.
Don't you see that by his grace.
I have been for many years now.
Careful to lead a chaste and sober life.
I concentrate on spiritual studies.
Resist vices.
Pray often,
Huh?
I am watchful against temptations.
I recount all my years in the bitterness of my soul as far as I can judge.
I have lived among the brethren without coral lived among the brethren.
Wait,
who are we talking about now?
Are we still talking about the young girl?
I had been submissive to authority responding to the beckon call of my superior
in the monastery.
Is this the girl?
I do not covet goods,
not mind.
Rather,
do I put myself and my goods at the service of others with sweat on my brow,
I eat my bread.
Yet in all of these practices,
there is evidence only of my fidelity.
Nothing of enjoyment.
I obey the commandments to the best of my ability,
I hope,
but in doing so,
my third,
my soul thirsts like a parched land.
If therefore he is to find my holocaust acceptable,
let him kiss me.
I entreat with a kiss of his mouth.
Halfway through this remarkable quotation,
the girl morphs into the monk,
the last part,
it's a monk talking not a virgin girl and yet this is a male monk yearning for
this male figure and he's doing this in a monastery.
Isn't this kind of odd?
He uses the eroticism of the song of songs not to get rid of eroticism?
I don't.
He's not.
I don't think he's telling the monk you're going to have sex with Jesus,
but he certainly doesn't get rid of the erotic at all.
He doesn't explain it away or try to get rid of it like origin would have done
previously or some of the,
you know,
the early Christian writers.
In fact,
he capitalizes on the erotic and even turns it into the home or erotic because
he's asking the monk to identify with the body of the girl and to yearn for this
male bridegroom.
So Bernard reads this text not only at a gala [inaudible] way so that the girl
represents the monk in a monastery who's trying to do the office.
He prays every night.
He does all the right things and he doesn't feel anything about it.
He feels dry and barren.
And so Bernard's using the erotic of the song of songs to enliven the daily
office of the monastery for the monks.
And then this other quotation,
this is where Bernard says,
oh,
everybody who's lived in monastic life knows that there are times when you go to
the church and you'd go to the,
and you pray in the altar and you don't feel anything.
You just feel,
you feel depressed,
you feel alone.
So he says,
men with an urge to frequent prayer will have experience with what I say.
Often enough,
when we approached the alter to pray,
you might not enrich initially.
Feel all excited about it.
Our hearts are dry and Luke warm,
but if we persevere,
there comes an unexpected infusion of grace.
Our breast expands the breasts of the monks.
Yeah,
our breast expands as it were.
Our interior is filled with an overflowing of love and if somebody should press
on them,
then this milk of sweet fecundity would gush forth in streaming richness.
He's talking about orgasm folks,
he,
you know,
he's describing orgasm,
the orgasm of a woman,
the breast filling up swelling,
and then experiencing this explosion.
Bernard is using orgasmic language taken from the song of songs to talk to a
bunch of monks in the middle of the night to get them to continue praying and to
get them more excited about giving themselves to Jesus the bridegroom.
This is part of the remarkable you reading of the text of the Bible that you get
in a premodern world where they seem to feel remarkably free to read these texts
as containing a lot more meanings than a historian like me would see them
containing.
Now,
I could go on and talk about the Thomas Aquinas step,
but it's just there as examples.
Aquinas is a wonderful example of how he quotes one interpretation of John Chris
System and then quotes another interpretation of Augustan and he doesn't decide.
He just says,
okay,
they're both there.
They're both valid.
He doesn't have any desire to narrow down the meaning of the text to one
meaning.
So I want you to,
uh,
think about this also.
These are legitimate ways to interpret this text.
At least they have been for much of the history of Christianity.
The modern world tended to reject them,
but if you look anywhere before the modern period,
you'll find them all over the place.
So experienced some of this stuff too.
When you go then to the Yale Art Gallery later this week.